[Applause]
destructive fires in the brazilian
amazon
have become an all-too-familiar
[Applause]
[Music]
storyline
[Music]
and right now the destruction is at a
10-year
high last year approximately
10 000 square kilometers of brazilian
rainforest were eliminated because of
fires
that's one lebanon or one connecticut
and in 2020 that number is expected to
rise by one
third
since fires are used to clear land after
trees have been felt
they are a really good indicator as to
where and at what
rate the amazon is shrinking
and contrary to president bolsonaro's
assertions
a contest
these fires are not just small
agriculture fires
they are actually deforestation fires
which are very often intentionally said
illegal
and the responsibility of a select few
deep have found that only two percent of
farmers in brazil
are responsible for more than 62 percent
of our illegal deforestation taking
place
inside private properties the impact
this destruction has for the climate is
enormous
roughly one gigaton of co2 equivalent
emissions
in 2019 were due to deforestation in the
amazon alone
compare that to germany iran and japan
amazon deforestation emissions give off
the equivalent of
entire countries
to understand why deforestation is such
a problem in brazil
we have to talk money forest is
worth only a fifth of what cleared land
is in the land market
so if you're thinking in terms of you
know leaving your farm for your children
and their
and their children if it's got a lot of
forest on it
it's worth a lot less money in seven out
of ten cases
deforested land will be used for cattle
a flourishing business since brazil is
not only the world's top exporter of
beef
but of the 10 million tons of beef that
brazil produced in 2019
around 8 million tons were consumed
domestically
to put that into perspective the average
brazilian eats around 25
kilo of beef every year that's the
equivalent of 20 hamburgers a month
making them one of the top beef features
in the world
[Music]
so do brazilians simply not care about
the amazon
officially brazil has very ambitious
laws to protect the amazon
eighty percent of private property in
the amazon has to be kept as forest
reserve
according to their forest code brazil's
biggest problem
is law enforcement or rather the lack of
it
you know i think there's a tendency to
assume that that
you know all farmers are just illegal
and and they want to be
but i think it's really important to
look at this and say wow what brazil is
trying to do
is pretty uh amazing unprecedented
unprecedented uh they need help
implementing the forest code which is
the most
ambitious private land forest
conservation
law anywhere in the world but that help
isn't coming from the baltimore
administration
quite the contrary the spending on
forest inspection has shrunk
to one third of its previous budget
and environmental fines handed out have
been in decline
since bolsonaro took office we have a
situation where
the first rangers who are doing a good
job who are going to the field and and
are basically fighting uh for illegal
deforestation
rather than being uh they be promoted
they have been fired
they have been demoted sent to other
places taking out of their roles
as far as rangers how effective strong
law enforcement can be
is evident in brazil's past the country
had its lowest deforestation rates
between 2010
and 2012. what happened is
it was all stick and no carrot there
were really no positive incentives for
the people who were complying with the
law and that's still the case today
and this probably won't change as long
as bolsonaro is president
at least not on a domestic level
the amazon plays a crucial role in our
world climate
so protecting it should be a global
initiative
and yet almost one-fifth of the beef
experts from brazil to the eu for
instance
are the product of deforestation but
experts say
a boycott would not solve the problem
only push it somewhere else however
incentivizing farmers to keep more of
their land as forest
shows a lot of promise it's 2020 and it
still doesn't pay to conserve forests if
you're a farmer in the amazon
and and we can change that experts
suggest
result-based reward programs that bypass
the federal government
altogether whereby individual countries
ngos or the eu could bring that money
directly to farmers
who are making an effort to reduce
deforestation
brazilians into a smaller amount all of
us
could also reduce their beef consumption
supplementing it
with other sources of protein
some of the best recipes in the world
are
are native amazon fish and
i think resuscitating and building them
on those expanding fish production
production to for to fish farming to
aquaculture
would be a wonderful way of diversifying
the income of cattle ranchers of
indigenous people
as we shift the protein source back to
what it was in the amazon
and then brazil and then regionally and
globally
[Music]
the amazon is not yet lost but
scientists fear that once
20 of the amazon is destroyed it won't
recover
and go into a process of civilization
we are currently at about 18 destruction
the clock is ticking
[Music]